Ron and Hermione are
practicing lifting feathers
into the air with magic.
Hermione can lift a feather
35 feet into the air, which
is 5 times as high as
Ron can lift a feather.
How high can Ron lift a
feather with his magic?
So Hermione, this 35 feet
is 5 times more than Ron.
So to figure out
what Ron can do,
we just take what Hermione
can do and divide by 5.
So what's 35 divided by 5?
Well, 5 times 7 is 35.
So 35 divided by 5 is 7.
So Ron can lift a feather
7 feet in the air.
So let's check our answer.
Now, if you have trouble
with this-- and we
could also look at
the hints for this.
So they show that Hermione can
lift a feather 35 feet, which
is 5 times higher than Ron.
So this could be the length
of how high Ron can raise it.
And so, if you were
to actually divide 35
into 5 equal sections,
so 5 times question mark
is 35, that's the same thing
as saying 35 divided by 5
is question mark.
And 35 divided by 5 is indeed 7.